all right joining us now Senator Lindsey
Graham who this weekend was campaigning
and endorsing president Trump as the
kickoff to the 2024 election cycle has
now begun Senator Graham good to have
you back all right before we get to that
so we agree on a lot of issues we don't
always agree over the years we've had
our differences I ca there's every once
in a while I want to read through this
television set and pull you by the tie
and kind of like say Lindsay wake up
what are you doing and that happened
over Christmas why can you explain to
this audience why on Earth knowing that
the Republicans are coming into the
house
oh you can't hear it's a great setup I'm
not dodging the question I can't hear uh
I believe you just had Rock can you hear
me I can hear you hear me yep okay
thumbs up you just had Ronald Reagan on
Ronald Reagan protected the defense
department and made it strong this
ominous Bill did suck you're absolutely
right we put 1.7 trillion dollars in a
pile nobody knew what was in it I had
three bad choices shut down the
government we're going to do that
continuing resolution which kills the
defense department inflation's at seven
percent I voted for the bill because it
increased defense spending by 10 percent
which means that we actually have more
money to defend the nation I'm hoping my
friends in the house can do a better job
so I'm not put in this position again
put to my house Republican colleagues
you send a bill over to the Senate that
cuts defense I'll try to kill it
all right can you hear me now senator
got you you got me all right I love how
you almost you kind of heard but didn't
even happen I was going to go a lot
harder I sort of knew where you were
going and you're right to be I listen I
get it I didn't like it either yeah I
didn't but you didn't have to go along
with it you could have worked with the
house but we'll go we'll save that for
another day um yeah let me ask you so
you with the president this weekend he
kicks off his campaign uh get your
endorsement gets the governor of South
Carolina's endorsement and what you said
this weekend was you know how many times
have we heard we like Trump policies but
we want somebody new and then you said
there are no Trump policies without
Donald Trump it's interesting you asked
that question because two potential
contenders uh in this nominating process
would be Nikki Haley and and former
Secretary of State Pompeo people we both
like and I asked both of them the same
question what policy differences do you
have with President Trump neither one of
them really had an answer on any policy
differences at all it seems like the
Trump agenda is the is the agenda for
the entire Republican party so that how
will other candidates distinguish
themselves against Donald Trump if they
agree with his policies
I really don't know but I do know this
we're lucky as a party to have Mike
Pompeo who was a terrific Secretary of
State Nikki Haley a strong voice in the
U.N for American first agenda my buddy
and
loved him Scott right we've got Mike
Pence maybe the most decent guy to ever
serving the government all talking about
running for president here's why I'm
with Trump
I know the downside of trump but let me
tell you about the upside of trump there
are no Trump policies without Donald
Trump you know why NATO gave 431 billion
dollars in defense spending increases
because they thought that Trump really
meant it when he said he was going to
pull out you know why the capital of we
moved the embassy of the United States
to Jerusalem every president before
Trump said I will do it but then all the
smart people said it will create World
War III Trump said I said I would do it
I would do it he is responsible for
securing the Border through his personal
will when he put tariffs on Chinese
products it scared the crap out of
Mexico and they said yes we'll be glad
to give you 28 000 troops we'll be glad
to keep people in Mexico because he
thought Trump they thought Trump would
put tariffs on Mexican policies there
are no Trump policies without the man
Donald Trump and to all these people who
are very talented I don't think you
could do what he could what he did and I
want him to have another shot unfinished
business
let me you know politics gets is a nasty
business you know as well as anybody and
you mentioned a lot of names uh you
mentioned Tim Scott Nikki Haley both
from your state of South Carolina uh
Mike Pompeo Larry Hogan's thinking about
it Chris Christie's thinking about it uh
then you've got Governor Glenn Younkin I
think the rumors are probably true that
he's thinking about it we keep hearing
Ron DeSantis he's been a great governor
for Florida
um I he's according to every report he's
thinking about it the question is you
know at the end of the day primaries
always get nasty look at your state of
South Carolina he used to be friends
with John McCain who did ticked me off
more than any one politician in the
world but you were friends with him okay
remember when it got to South Carolina
how vicious that campaign was with
George W bush I don't so it always
starts out people trying to be friendly
it never ends up that way does it
now we need to get ready for a real
spirited contest now why Trump now you
mentioned like DeSantis if you try to
tell me that Ron desantos is not a good
governor in Florida I'm not going to
listen to you if you try to tell me Mike
Pompeo is not qualified to be president
I'm not going to listen to you because I
think he is I am for Trump not because
of the flaws of anybody else I'm for
Donald Trump because I know what I'm
going to get we need somebody that on
day one can get this country back on
track that can secure our border and
bring order out of chaos somebody the
Russians and the Chinese fear somebody
that can take the fight to the
terrorists the Abraham records the
result of Donald Trump impressing the
Arabs and the Israelis he is the best
solution to the problems we face not
because of the flaws of others but
because what I know he can do and I'm
telling your listeners right now when
you hear I like Trump
policies but I'm ready for somebody new
there are no Trump policies without
Donald Trump
Senator Lindsey Graham always great to
have you thank you hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else